other heated school board meeting it is
happening right now we're keeping an eye
on it as a political battle within ccsd
comes to a head trustee is set to make
two crucial votes with the
superintendent and board president's
jobs both on the line sasha loftis
joining us now live near flamingo and
eastern where that meeting is well
underway sasha
denise and bryan tonight's meeting has
been going on for about an hour and a
half and we are still in the public
comment portion with dozens lining up to
share their concerns as that contentious
battle within the school district is
expected to come to a head with two
crucial votes tonight now the main
talker tonight is the future of
superintendent dr jesus jarrah's job
trustees will discuss the possible
termination of his contract that was
brought up by three board members linda
cavazos job as board president also on
the line as trustees will vote on
whether to strip her of that title three
separate trustees are pushing to oust
cavazos as president including trustee
williams who claimed president cavazos
bullied other board members now cavazos
denied those allegations now back out
here live to pass each item four of the
seven trustees would have to vote yes we
will of course keep you posted again the
public comment portion is still
continuing should continue for a while
longer so no word on when we will get to
those agenda items for a vote but we
will of course keep you updated on aaron
online reporting live tonight sasha
loftis live local now